you shaved the iconic nick offerman
mustache yes the the headline is
character actor changes look yeah crazy
are you getting what kind of response
are you getting from people people are
not happy I've I've seen in social media
it's been pointed out to me that people
say very mean things to me which I
understand I can work it into a
compliment for Parks and Recreation but
still I want to let them know that it's
my face the refer they look what kind of
mean tweets are we talking about here um
well there there was one that said you
know I saw Nick Offerman without his
moustache and it made me vomit
and you know I just want people to
remember that my mother and father gave
me this face and they might not want to
hear that it nauseates people maybe it's
just they're they're so in love with the
character Ron Swanson that that that's
all they're talking about they're not
talking specifically about your face
well that's that's the the kind of but
that's the kind of math I have to do to
go to sleep at night as well digit
they're just telling me that they love
me
yeah from before from before
equivocation I think you look fantastic
by the way that's generous
your manly fellow thank you you uh I've
no need for number years and we've had
many discussions about your your
beginnings in the Midwest you grew up in
the Midwest that's right about 15
minutes from andy's hometown of
Yorkville which we mentioned a couple of
days ago on the show no kidding
on Monday I don't know if you guys saw a
Monday show
[Applause]
a whole audience that saw Monday's show
incredible uh that's the kind of fan
loyalty you can't purchase I just saw a
brief shot of Andy sitting on a cake yet
it made me strangely to miss it but we
haven't heard a word yeah I can give you
a website laughter we're done no no
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please